this a scandal that came out I won't say
the word but this woman falsely accused
several young men of doing something to
her these young men try to delete
themselves because it was absolutely
light now evidence came out recently
where she went to the store bought a
hammer beat herself oh my goodness oh my
God
if it wasn't for other men
coming around and supporting these young
men and they were these these older men
were canceled for because they were
trying to
um support men who did a essay and just
because she was a woman she was believed
and I'm not saying that doesn't happen
happen to my mother that's how I have an
older my older sister came from that
when she was 14. so of course I actually
come from a family that's happened but I
still know several stories of women who
have falsely accused ruined these young
men's lives